well a new year is upon us what do you
think what are you gonna do this year
what's your life gonna look like you
know when people are doing their debt
free screams and when I talk to people
who have done great things with their
lives whether it's weight loss or change
their marriage or built a business or a
ministry or become successful in an area
I almost always hear from those people
that they they have a really big why
they have a reason for doing the thing
more than just doing the thing we got
out of debt so we could change our
family tree we got out of debt so that
we could give more they didn't get out
of debt just to get money you always got
to have a big reason and the big reason
is called having a vision
you know first year but we're always
taught to dream but not to be a dreamer
dreamers don't do anything we want to
have big dreams but dreams then when
they turn into your Hawaii they become a
vision and if you stop at just having a
wise just having a vision
you never really accomplished anything
but that should be the the gas and the
engine that causes things to move
forward you have to have a big why a big
vision a big starts with a dream and
evolve Xin to a vision and then when it
actually goes to work vision when it
goes to work is called a goal and here
we are with a new year upon us and you
need to have big dreams that lead to
clear vision a big Y that leads you into
doing the details to win called
goal-setting I'm not talking about
namby-pamby with New Year's resolutions
I'm talking about real goal setting
goals that work when you set goals that
are gonna work they have five components
to them their first and second specific
and they're measurable I want to lose
weight well you'll never lose weight it
is measurable but you're not specific
I want to lose 30 pounds oh now we're on
to something
now it's specific and now it's
measurable
the next thing you ask yourself is when
do I want to lose 30 pounds and how many
different times do I want to do it maybe
once is enough for some people you want
to lose 30 pounds over the next 30 years
that's a pound a year you can probably
pull that off right see as soon as you
put a time limit on your goal that's
measurable in specific suddenly the math
starts unfolding very naturally thirty
pounds over three months for instance
that's reasonable that's ten pounds a
month that's doing half pounds a week
immediately when you do that the next
thing that will unfold in your brain is
what has to be true for me to do that
what has to be true for me to get out of
debt what has to be true for me to
increase the quality of my spiritual
life what has to be true to lose thirty
pounds what has to be true to increase
my income two hundred thousand a year
what has to be true that's not true
today well you would change your caloric
intake you'd lower the number of
calories that you're taking in and you'd
increase your water intake and you'd
increase your aerobic activity we know
that about losing weight and you have to
you have to slow down how much you eat
and you have to increase how much you
exercise 100 percent of the time to lose
weight that works unless you get sick
that's the only way to lose weight right
so you had no what you have to do goals
that work also need to be your goals my
wife wants me to lose weight yeah you
never will my mother wants me to make
more money you never will my father
always wanted me to be a dentist he'll
be a lousy one I don't want to go to
your dentistry practice it's not a good
thing
so they need to be your goals and lastly
and most importantly specific measurable
have a time limit and they're your goals
most important one is they have to be in
writing in writing is the only way it
works the Bible says in a back kick to
to write the vision and make it plain
when you write it down something happens
and you need goals in several different
areas of your life this year you need
financial goals you need intellectual
goals you're gonna read or take a class
you need family goals you need
your goals and physical goals any goals
in your career and you need social goals
when you put those on a map on a graph
it looks like what Zig Ziglar used to
call the Wheel of Life and you need to
set goals in every one of those areas
you can take control of these areas of
your life you just have to make
different decisions you have to have a
good reason and then you have to follow
the rules of goal-setting for instance
you can take control of your money
Winston Churchill said that mighty oaks
start with small acres and the acorns
mmm they not all of them become giant
trees we know that but for sure they're
not going to become a giant tree unless
you start so you have to start right now
maybe this time you go through Financial
Peace University it's the money class
that five million people have done to
take control of their money once and for
all the average family pays all fifty
three hundred dollars in debt the
savings twenty seven hundred dollars in
the first 90 days that's an eight
thousand dollar turn in just three
months that's a big deal
you know Financial Peace University is
pretty easy to get in it's got a local
class and when you buy it now we've
changed the way it's structured and it's
a much better deal than it's ever been
now you get every dollar plus where you
have Bank connectivity for a whole year
for your every dollar built into your
Financial Peace University and you get
access to all the videos audios and all
the classroom materials and everything
online to use at your leisure at your
speed you can turn it into home study if
you want to for a year and on top of
that you get the kit and go to the local
class so go to the class take it online
use the every dollar all of that oh and
free shipping now this is hundreds of
dollars worth of stuff we've added to it
and the investment is only 129 bucks
it's a deal maybe you're ready to start
your investing and you put it off long
enough retirement may not be something
you want to think about but you need to
get control of your future jump on Chris
Hogan's website at Chris Hogan 360
dot-com and
do your riq find out what your
retirement IQ is your retire inspired
quotient jump in there figure that out
that's Chris Hogan 360 calm that's a
completely free tool and you don't want
to miss that let me tell you something
else that's free and that will rock your
world and we're doing it right here at
the first of the year brand-new thing a
seven day jumpstart email series you're
gonna get an email to move you along
with helpful articles free resources
tools inspiration and information to
help you attack your money goals one a
day for seven days the seven day
jumpstart email series is completely
free and so all you got to do is just go
to Dave Ramsey com look for the seven
day jumpstart and sign up today or get
your riq at chris hogan 360 calm or jump
on Dave Ramsey calm and get your a
Financial Peace University going one
hundred twenty nine dollars shipping is
free you don't miss these things if you
don't set and execute on your goals and
no one's gonna do it for you
this is your year baby time to make it
happen happy new year from the Dave
Ramsey show